[Music]
brady quinn fox sports college and nfl
game analyst and he will be in ann arbor
it's number five michigan on saturday
against the ohio state big noon kickoff
on fox
and uh you can also listen to him every
weekday morning two bro up two bros two
bros and a cup of joe two bros with
lavar arrington and jonas knox and you
can catch them on fox sports radio good
morning brady how are you bud
i'm doing well dan uh you're looking
quite dapper thank you and you're on
your pumpkin colored sweatshirt thank
you brady thank you that's dapper dan
that's how we came up with that uh that
expression all right tell me how
michigan wins this game
uh michigan wins this game if aiden
hutchinson the defensive end and david
ojabo their other defensive end do what
they've done all year and pester the
opposing quarterback they're both tied
for the league and sacks for the big ten
and if you look at cj stroud
his completion percentage drops
dramatically from a clean pocket versus
under pressure he completes about 73 of
his passes from a clean pocket about 53
when he's under pressure and that's
something that he really hasn't faced
much this season but when you watch him
on tape
when guys start to get close you can
tell he doesn't like it he doesn't want
to take off and run he wants this to be
a seven on seven essentially where he
doesn't have to worry about getting hit
that's what we saw last week versus
michigan state which was one of the
better pass rushing teams but because
how that game started off there was just
really no ability for them to get back
into that thing rush the passer they got
pretty worn out in particular on the
outside how important is this game for
jim horrible
i mean you could put it up there with
pretty much every year they've played
ohio state and trying to
find one find a win in a way of
kind of staking his flag in this rivalry
and saying all right i've arrived you
know i did it as a player but now i've
arrived as a coach and i think that
would be a huge signal for this program
you know it's it's funny and the reason
why i say that is like penn state who
just signed james franklin to that
extension
you know they've at least beat ohio
state like they've really showcased i
think in recruiting two they're a little
bit more competitive in recruiting
versus ohio state
um and i think in order for mission to
get back they've got to do it at least
once they've got they've got to be able
to pitch that to those recruits once
because if i'm a recruit and i was one
at a you know ohio state michigan
and if i was looking at these two
schools and and you have this long line
of ohio state wins versus michigan
as much as they can preach to you well
you can be the change come to michigan
help us beat ohio state you can be the
change
you're still going to say i'd rather go
with the team has a better chance of
winning a national championship
if michigan beats ohio state they've got
the edge going up against an opponent
they already beat wisconsin in the big
ten championship i assume that's who
it's going to be and then a path
obviously to playing in the college
football playoff they sit down at five
so this is monumental
in the case that i think jim harbaugh
makes
not only
this saturday but also moving forward to
every recruit and every michigan fan
that he's preaching why he should be the
guy there in ann arbor why is it a guy
who played the position can't find a
great quarterback
i don't even know that it's not that he
can't find one i mean jj mccarthy is one
of the higher recruited quarterbacks
that's come on this roster came back to
merit2 as a little higher recruiter it's
more of the development piece
and i think that's a twofold discussion
it's it's the sense of what offense and
system are you running
and i think he's kind of found something
that works for them now with josh gaddis
calling plays
um but it's more of the development of
finding that guy who's able to kind of
take over a game when they need him to
most
so
it's been those two things that have
been elusive for them i do think they've
found that rhythm now getting back to
the rushing attack the rushing game i
mean if you've looked traditionally what
has won the big ten as much as we want
to talk about how talented ohio state is
throwing the football around they've
also i think three of the last four
years if they're not mistaken led the
big ten in rushing like that's a big
component that's what michigan started
out this season doing and playing good
defense and then bringing kate mcnamara
along who now has two plus touchdown
pass in the past you know a few games
and so they're starting to evolve there
we're talking to brady quinn former
notre dame quarterback uh he will be in
ann arbor it'll be fox big noon kickoff
that will be ohio state against michigan
i also wonder about this and and you
can't help but speculate
that if jim harbaugh doesn't beat ohio
state this time around
does he look at that chicago bears
opening
it's going to be open
and i just wonder you don't want to turn
your back on your alma mater but that
might be one of those where both parties
say you know what maybe it's just not
going to work out like we thought it was
potentially you know but but i think if
if i was jim harbaugh and i'm looking at
that next jump
i i better make sure that it's one that
i feel really confident that it's
position where i can go and have success
right away
you have justin fields and he's clearly
are well aware of how good justin fields
is um even though they didn't play each
other last year i think he's seen enough
tape on justin fields to know how good
he is what he can't be as a quarterback
but there's a lot of other decisions
that you've got to make with that roster
a lot of other things that i think you
know you would probably rather take over
the bears when aaron rodgers isn't a
part of the packers anymore maybe he's
not after this year i don't know
but the reality is
if that's the only job he's offered and
he feels like there's just too much
pressure and they've reworked this
contract and
he just wants to jump back to the pro
level feels like he can be more
successful there sure you're going to
take what's there
but i think with this next jump he's got
to be careful because the next jump
could be his last one whereas michigan
has been by his side
they are still supporting him through
all of this uh and as much as michigan
fans want to complain about lack of
success they're much better off with jim
harbaugh than they were before he got
there like let's not forget that they're
recruiting well they're pumping guys out
in the nfl they're averaging about you
know nine wins or so uh you'd say maybe
before whatever you know last year was
with the coveted year but that's what
they're averaging now which is better
than what they were so i just think he's
got to be careful about that next jump
because it could be his very last and
he's made them relevant um you know that
that we we do know about michigan uh
we're curious about michigan but we know
that season always comes down against uh
ohio state how
safe should cincinnati feel at number
four in the rankings
i don't feel like they should feel safe
only in the sense that you know look
they're sitting there at four i don't
think they have any room for error you
know they're favored by a couple
touchdowns versus east carolina this
week right you know a close win versus
east carolina i believe it's on the road
you know i don't think they're getting
docked or pushed back for it i just
think they have to worry about they have
to win that's all they need to do and i
think they're in because the playoff
committee has already you know put them
in this position so far
and you know you're assuming one of
those teams in the top four is going to
drop out right at least we're assuming
georgia's going to beat alabama in the
sec championship game so at worst maybe
you know our best maybe they move up to
three but i i think they should feel
pretty safe i mean notre dame's behind
them they're not gonna move ahead of
them unless they drop a game probably in
the aac championship game like that's
where it gets a little sticky like they
both have one loss even though they beat
them head to head they don't have the
conference championship to wave over
notre dame and then you can make the
case their names played better football
of late
with the exception of last week where
cincinnati obviously played extremely
well blowing out smu
but i just i don't look at anyone behind
them
being able to leapfrog them
unless you know they really falter and
end up dropping either this week's game
or obviously you know their conference
championship which i think that's the
only way they fall out of this thing at
this point
we saw what happened with the giants
yesterday that
jason garrett was fired the offensive
coordinator
what does that matter to a team that is
not a good offensive team no matter
who's calling the plays
yeah i mean it's been a lack of
execution they can use jason garrett as
the scapegoat the reality is daniel
jones turns over the football way too
much
i think he's got between seven
interceptions seven fumbles this year i
mean it's just it's not a formula for
success he's in his third year starting
and that's been his issue the entire
time you know saquon hasn't been healthy
it hasn't been as impactful the
offensive line that they continue to
keep trying to building upon it's never
really messed and developed the
chemistry they need um you know
there's just so many different issues
offensively
i don't think it's going to matter that
they're changing out jason garrett and
even though freddie kitchens who's had
success doing this before helen got a
head coaching job i don't know that
that's going to matter when it's all
said and done i think this is more of a
move that signals when you start firing
coordinators
that means you as the head coach are
feeling the heat and that someone above
you is telling you like we got to make a
change i'm not going to say for change's
sake but for optics because if we don't
then then you're next you know you're
the next thing coming so
they're just trying to figure out a way
of winning football games looking more
competitive to have some sort of
optimism going in the offseason
otherwise
i think you got to be careful if you're
joe judge obviously david gettleman too
with the way these draft picks have kind
of worked out or lack of development
they all could be moving on they all
could be starting over again we had a
topic yesterday the most awkward
quarterbacking situation
not necessarily bad
but awkward uh the niners with what's
going on with jimmy g that they're
they're winning like do you what if he
gets you to the playoffs do you then say
hey thanks some nice parting gifts uh
the eagles are they gonna be all in on
jalen hurts the falcons do you stay with
matt ryan uh the dolphins with what's
going on there the saints it feels like
they have three quarterbacks but they
don't have one quarterback there
which
quarterbacking situation is the most
awkward to you
uh i mean you name two that i think are
really awkward you know you got the
green bay packers and their success that
jordan loves sitting right there and
aaron's playing banged up and you feel
like there's the potential based on the
reworked contract that he's not even
back next year and so how's that gonna
work out because i look at the packers
as one of the best if not the best team
in the nfl
so there's that out there like are you
really gonna part ways after what could
be a super bowl winning season
um there's a lot of awkwardness to that
right as far as far as what it looks
like at least now heading forward and
then the other one is seattle
i mean we
obviously know
russell wilson
for some reason he has got the intention
or was floated out there that he maybe
you know would have some other teams you
want to be traded to
and they've never experienced you know a
losing season but it seems like it's
headed in that direction right now
the awkwardness of pete carr on the
press conferences the offense hasn't
looked like what they needed to now he's
got her finger that he's trying to
overcome
which i think he came back too early
i've dealt with that injury before um
and i think it's hard to adjust how your
you know your hand feels throwing the
football after that injury so you've got
all these things and meanwhile like
lingering on the outside is oh yeah he
kind of threw out some teams that he'd
want to go to in the off season and
that's still lingering over there so
is this going to get to a point where
maybe after the season in seattle they
have their first losing season together
pete and russell say hey why don't you
guys start over we'll go our separate
ways i mean
those are more i think the awkward
points like because we're kind of half
that halfway point now that i think
those two teams are kind of staring at
least at down the road uh at the halfway
point of the season
i don't think russ is there in seattle
next year
i i just i think there's got to be a
change for him
i wonder if pete carroll would leave
if russ would want to stay
uh but it feels like
russ is going to be on another team next
year i just can't imagine the giants
what about the giants i mean i feel like
they're if they move on obviously
they've already moved off from the oc
if they end up moving on from you know
ghetto man or phantom moving on from joe
judge as well
that's a team that look it's a big
market you know he's a part of a power
couple
uh and that's a roster with when you
talk about evan ingram you talk about
kedarius tony i think he's got a lot of
ability uh sterling shepard kenny
gallaudet is on that roster saquon
barkley too
there's a lot of weapons and that's a
kind of winnable division i i don't know
i just think that market everything else
i think he wants to get to the east
coast especially with sierra you know
they want to be a part of that
that's that's one that i would keep an
eye on
safe travels to ann arbor are they going
to be nice to you in ann arbor
um i mean i
only started once there we won
um
so we'll see you know i feel like
there's not really much trash talking
they can do there i told the fans there
in east lansing that back in i think it
was with 2004 2006 i bought real estate
uh there in east lansing so i said make
sure they take care of it for me while
i'm gone i've got a little real estate
in ann arbor too so hopefully the fans
are taking care of my property there on
the field this this might not help but
what you're saying now this might not
won't
yeah we'll figure it out you might get
mooned they might you know pull their
pants down and moon you and ann arbor
well
michigan fans are a little more classy
though they don't they don't spread the
cheeks
you know i guess that's the difference
in a state school or private institution
i still can't imagine what's that first
time you pull in there with notre dame
on the team bus and then you got all of
these guys who were pulling their pants
down and you know mooning you
it's a it's appalling it's like uh well
look we're all we're all experiencing
thanksgiving tomorrow uh it's not overly
pretty sometimes looking at the back
side of your turkey the way it's stuffed
in there all right
and it kind of resembles that so i hope
everyone has a wonderful thanksgiving
meal tomorrow yeah
that's incredible
great memory yeah great image there hey
uh safe travels great to talk to you
thank you buddy
hey thankful for you guys i hope
everyone enjoys their thanksgiving
that's brady quinn you can listen to him
monday through friday two pros and a cup
of joe with lavar arrington jonas knox